it takes supernatural powers to play the
online fantasy game Aion
but behind the scenes it's a team of
mortals who plan out every mission and
sketch out every detail of the online
characters online games have really
taken off in recent years the game Forge
company has some twenty games and it's
lineup most of them in-house productions
some games are produced very quickly in
five or six months while many games need
one and a half years because they're
very complicated and when you add sound
and everything it can turn into a really
big production kind of sad sack was
better founded 10 years ago the German
online game provider has seen rapid
growth nowadays 450 people work at game
forge headquarters in Karlsruhe
developing even more new cyber games for
the world we're in more than 75
countries and we work in more than 50
languages and for every language we have
a native speakers sitting here with us
they're the ones who manage the
worldwide gaming communities and in
every country more and more players are
switching from PCs to other devices as
both attend a big trend for us in the
gaming industry is the ability to go
mobile people used to play games on
their PCs or on consoles in their living
rooms with today's new terminals you can
play on your telephone or tablet and
that opens up a whole new time frame
it's engaged in gansan OA site fed stuff
and new business models playing online
games is mostly free at first sight game
forge creates revenue by offering
virtual goods extras for the game
figures that brings in more than 100
million euros a year for the company but
first the goods and games are thoroughly
tested if I were a user who had never
seen this before is it clear to me is it
well structured is it well balanced me
does a thing suit the game or is it too
strong or too weak it has to all fit
nicely into the game if the players
answer yes that means more revenue for
Gameforge even so the company can hardly
afford to take a creative break in this
fast-moving industry